.
* Glockenbimmeln,
helle Hackbrettmusik *
* Beschwingte Streicherklänge *
Jedes Jahr
beginnen mehr als 100'000 Menschen
ein neues Leben in der Schweiz.
Aus verschiedenen Kulturen
und sozialen Schichten,
hoffen sie alle, dass die Schweiz
ihr neues Zuhause wird.
Das ist schön!
Doch nicht alle bleiben.
Jedes Jahr kehren auch mehrere 10'000
Menschen in ihre alte Heimat zurück.
Dies ist die Geschichte
von vier Familien,
die wir in den letzten Jahren
bei ihrer Einwanderung in die Schweiz
begleitet haben.
Was ist aus ihnen geworden?
Sind sie geblieben?
Und haben sie ihr Glück gefunden?
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Aziz Abdulkarim,
mit seiner Familie gekommen,
um dem Krieg in Syrien zu entfliehen.
Sommer 2014.
Über die Türkei
schaffen sie es bis in die Schweiz.
Sie suchen Sicherheit
und erhalten Asyl.
Ein neues Leben beginnt.
An diesen beiden Orten
bekommen Sie Informationen,
wie Sie Ihre Diplome
anerkennen lassen können.
Doch das ist schwierig.
Der ehemalige Chefarzt
muss wieder ganz von vorne anfangen.
Mein Leben in der Schweiz
ist ein einziges Warten,
Warten, Warten ...
* Vogelzwitschern *
Iain McKay,
der Schotte aus Deutschland.
Sein Neuanfang: in Disentis.
Uh!
Oh!
Die alte Heimat
war ihm zu eng geworden.
Leah.
- Leah, freut mich.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi, willkommen!
Der Englischlehrer will in Graubünden
ein neues Kapitel aufschlagen.
How do you do?
- How do you do?
You guys are well-trained.
How are you?
Der Plan: Iain will zunächst
mit den beiden Töchtern vorausgehen.
Seine Frau Marion und der Sohn
sollen ein Jahr später nachkommen.
* Iain seufzt. *
Yummy.
Doch die Trennung tut weh. Auch mit
der Integration im Dorf harzt es.
Und so platzt der Traum vom neuen
Leben nach wenigen Monaten.
Wir wollten ein bisschen zu viel.
In Meissen hatten wir
ein tolles Leben und wir dachten,
hier könnten wir es
noch besser haben.
Das war unser grösster Fehler.
Lisa, die Portugiesin, auf der Suche
nach Einkommen und Liebe.
* Verzerrte Frauenstimme *
Gestern hatte ich Spätdienst.
Mit der Arbeit
hat es problemlos geklappt.
Und heute habe ich Frühdienst,
also ... Das passiert.
Lisa kam 2014 in die Schweiz.
Seither arbeitet sie
in einem Alters- und Pflegeheim.
Dabei hilft es ihr, dass sie
bereits fliessend Deutsch spricht.
Hallo. Guten Morgen.
Da bin ich wieder.
Lisa ist integriert.
Doch wenn immer möglich,
reist sie zurück nach Portugal,
besucht ihre beiden Söhne
und ihre alte Mutter.
* Sie sprechen portugiesisch. *
Lisa ist geschieden
und muss ihre studierenden Söhne
von der Schweiz aus
finanziell unterstützen.
Dort fühlt sie sich oft einsam.
Ich meine, es gibt Tage und Momente,
die schon schwierig genug sind.
Ja, Scheisse,
allein sein ist nicht einfach -
besonders in einem fremden Land.
* Glockenbimmeln *
Rahul Budhwar und Megha Goyal,
die Manager aus Indien.
* Orientalische Klänge *
Beide kommen
aus der Hauptstadt Delhi.
Ein geordnetes Leben, zusammen mit
Tochter Dia und den Eltern von Rahul.
Nachdem er ein Jobangebot als CEO
einer Schweizer Firma erhalten hat,
beginnt für sie in der Schweiz
ein Alltag ohne Hausangestellte.
Bisher hatte Rahul
für alles Bedienstete.
Not even in the bathroom ...
In der Schweiz
muss er sich alleine durchschlagen,
um die Ankunft seiner Frau
und Tochter vorzubereiten.
Alltägliche Dinge wie Einkaufen
sind für ihn Neuland.
Mann, ist das schwer.
Ich brauche eine Pause.
Ich hätte einen Wagen nehmen sollen.
Der Inder schlägt sich durch
so gut er kann.
(Mit englischem Akzent)
"Weissbohnen an Tomatensauce."
It is white beans and tomato sauce.
In der Schweiz wagen sich die beiden
zum ersten Mal in ihrem Leben
gemeinsam ans Abenteuer
selbst kochen.
Das ist gar nicht so kompliziert.
Indisches Essen
sieht kompliziert aus,
aber eigentlich
ist es wirklich einfach.
Ich glaube, wir sind hier organi-
sierter und respektvoller geworden.
Z.B. spülen wir jetzt unsere
eigenen Kaffeetassen bei der Arbeit.
Yellow ... what are the yellow?
Orange, brown.
Drei Jahre ist es her,
dass die Familie in die Schweiz kam.
In Indien war die Shoppingmall
ihr Wochenendausflugsziel.
In der Schweiz
geht es raus in die Natur.
Siehst du das am Baum?
Welche Frucht ist das?
Ich weiss es nicht.
- Kann man das essen?
Auf dem Pfannkuchen.
- Ah, daran erinnerst du dich.
Ich denke, das ist dieselbe Frucht.
Das ist schön.
Ich mache mal ein Foto.
Die Inder geniessen die Schweiz.
Wir kommen jeden Tag
aus dem Haus und denken:
"Was für ein perfektes Land."
Ich meine, die Infrastruktur,
die Natur, die Sauberkeit ...
Es ist einfach immer schön,
sobald man vor die Tür geht.
Very nice!
Wir haben alle Familien gebeten,
sich Episoden
aus der Vergangenheit anzuschauen.
* Hupen *
Die Welt der Budhwars
vor vier Jahren.
Ich frühstücke mal.
Megha Goyal wird von ihrem Chauffeur
zur Arbeit gefahren.
Ich verbringe jeden Tag
2-3 Std. im Auto.
Ich hasse es.
Was für eine Verschwendung
von Zeit und Benzin.
Das mag ich hier in Indien
überhaupt nicht.
Fester Bestandteil
des Lebens in Indien:
Familien-Events wie die Zeremonie zur
Einweihung eines neuen Apartments.
* Sprechgesang auf Hindi *
Wenn ich das sehe,
vermisse ich meine Familie.
* Sprechgesang auf Hindi *
Damals hatte ich Angst, zu gehen.
Unser ganzes Leben
war super eingespielt.
Und plötzlich
macht der Mann Karriere
und man muss
aus der Komfortzone raus.
In ein Land, wo man niemanden kennt,
wo alles neu ist,
weit weg von der Familie -
das hat mir Angst gemacht.
Ich musste meinen Job aufgeben,
das war ein totaler Programmwechsel,
aber ich denke,
ich hab's gut hingekriegt.
Inzwischen
machen sie's wie die Schweizer.
Nach der Wanderung wird eingekehrt.
10 Fr., bitte.
- Kann ich mit Karte bezahlen?
EC, Post und Lunch-Check.
- Okay. That's fine. Make bar then.
Auch wenn es manchmal hapert,
die deutsche Sprache
ist Teil ihres Lebens geworden.
Ich denke, es ist einfach.
Nein, sehr schwer.
- Sehr einfach.
Aber ich habe keine Zeit ...
... um Unterricht zu nehmen.
Wir haben viel Arbeit.
Und keine Freizeit.
Keine Freizeit.
Seht ihr die Werbung,
da, wo die Dame steht?
Da sind
zwei leckere Eiscremes drauf.
Als ich mir das näher
angeschaut habe, habe ich gesehen,
dass da "Hundeglace"
geschrieben steht. - What?
Eiscreme für Hunde.
Das sieht superlecker aus.
Wirklich?
Dia, möchtest du ein Hundeeis?
Nein.
- Das ist sicher lecker.
In der Schweiz
verbringt Rahul wesentlich mehr Zeit
mit seiner Tochter als in Indien.
Just relax.
Das ist schön.
Glücklich sein hängt letztlich
nicht von besonderen Sachen ab.
Es sind die kleinen Freuden,
wie diese hier.
Ah, cool, Dia!
Das war aber schnell!
* Arabische Musik im Autoradio *
So in etwa sah es aus,
als der Syrer Aziz Abdulkarim
das erste Mal die Schweiz erblickte.
Vier Jahre später ist es Alltag.
Die Fahrstrecke zur Arbeit.
Ich arbeite als Assistenzarzt
in der Abteilung für innere Medizin.
Da gibt es eine Notaufnahme
und eine normale Station.
Das ist jetzt fast das Gleiche,
was ich auch in Syrien gemacht habe.
In Syrien
war Aziz ein angesehener Chefarzt.
Heute arbeitet er als Assistenzarzt
in einem Regionalspital
im Kanton Waadt.
Immerhin, denn lange war nicht klar,
ob der syrische Flüchtling
in der Schweiz seinen Job - und
sein Ansehen - zurückbekommen würde.
Asylgesuch anerkannt,
Aufenthaltsbewilligung B -
das war vor fünf Jahren
noch ganz anders.
Auch Aziz und seine Familie
blicken zurück.
Aziz ist auf dem Weg zu einem Vor-
stellungsgespräch im Unispital Genf.
Mit grossen Hoffnungen.
Hello, Abdul Karim?
- Yes, Aziz Abdulkarim.
Nice to meet you. I'm Dr. Stäger.
Der syrische Arzt hofft,
einen grossen Schritt in Richtung
neues Leben machen zu können.
Also,
wenn ich richtig verstanden habe,
möchten Sie bei uns in der Poly-
klinik ein Praktikum absolvieren,
um zu sehen,
wie unser Medizinwesen funktioniert.
Oui. Genau, das ist das eine.
Und dann möchte ich
mein Studium vervollständigen
und hier als Arzt arbeiten.
Okay.
Ich dachte,
das Gespräch sei gut verlaufen.
Das war aber nicht so.
Ich habe das falsch verstanden.
Diese komplizierte Prozedere ...
Das war wirklich schwierig für mich.
Am besten wäre, wenn Sie hier
wie ein Student beginnen
und mit den anderen Ärzten
mitlaufen würden.
Oui.
- Okay?
Das war ein Schock für mich.
Als ob all meine Studien
nichts wert wären.
Als wir aus Syrien geflüchtet sind,
dachte ich: "In der Schweiz ..."
"Ich habe bereits
eine Spezialisierung,
da werde ich
sicher eine Arbeit finden,
weil ich ja bereits
ein Facharzt bin."
Aber dem war nicht so.
Aziz fängt wieder ganz unten an.
Immerhin,
eineinhalb Jahre nach dem Gespräch
arbeitet er wieder in einem Spital.
Die Portugiesin Lisa
hat es vom Strand Portugals
nach Ilanz, Graubünden, verschlagen.
Die Arbeit läuft,
doch Lisa vermisst ihr Familien-
und Sozialleben der alten Heimat.
Abwechslung bringen ihr
v.a. die Shopping-Touren.
Dieselben Läden - immer wieder.
Kann ich mich umschauen?
- Gerne. - Danke.
Sonst rufen Sie mich.
- Ja.
Ich werde immer die Modemaus sein.
Für mich ist wichtig,
dass es feminin bleibt.
Jetzt gehe ich z.B.
in die Läden rein und raus.
Die Leute wissen schon,
dass ich oft nichts kaufe,
aber einfach
gerne Einkaufsbummel mache.
Durch die paar Läden, die es gibt,
ist man schnell durch.
Die Leute kennen mich schon.
Ich gehe jetzt
eine Woche an den Strand.
Weisst du, es ist gemütlich ...
Das ist jetzt meine Ecke geworden.
Das bedeutet ...
Wenn ich nach Portugal fliege
und wieder zurückkomme,
freue ich mich auf meine Ecke.
Das ist mein Platz.
Da sind meine Sachen.
Und das ist ...
halt wie ein Zuhause.
Auch Lisa blickt zurück
in ihr altes Leben.
* Sanfte Klarinettenmusik *
Im Norden Portugals unterstützt sie
ihre beiden arbeitslosen Söhne
so gut es geht mit Geld
aus der Schweiz und mit Zuspruch.
Darüber hinaus muss sie
für ihre kranke Mutter
eine Pflege organisieren.
Das alles kostet Geld
und dieses Geld muss sie
in der Schweiz erwirtschaften.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi.
Na, was stricken Sie denn?
Ich weiss es nicht. Vielleicht für
die Söhne oder für jemand anderes.
Ah, okay. Also für mich
dürfen Sie auch ein Paar stricken.
Ja.
- Wenn Sie Lust haben.
Ich hatte schon immer geplant,
meinen Kindern das geben zu können,
damit sie sich ausbilden können
und etwas fürs Leben haben.
Das wollte ich
auch weiterhin machen können.
Und das hat mir ...
In Portugal habe ich dann langsam
gemerkt, das werde ich ...
Die Krise wurde immer stärker,
besonders in meinem,
im Textilbereich.
Ich habe mich da finanziell
nicht durchsetzen können.
Das waren zwei grosse Jungs
und eine Wohnung,
das war ziemlich viel.
Die letzten Jahre:
eine Zeit der Entbehrungen.
Aber auch eine Zeit, in der sich Lisa
einen Traum erfüllen konnte.
Schau mal, mein Auto!
Tipptopp.
Aber ich habe das Auto immer noch.
Es ist gut, es funktioniert.
Mein ganzes Leben lang,
auch als ich verheiratet war,
hat das mit den Autos
immer mein Mann gemacht.
Das mache ich jetzt für mich
mit meinem Geld.
Da war ich noch extrem emotional.
Dass man für sich selbst
so viel Geld braucht,
das verstehe ich gar nicht.
Ich habe gedacht,
das hat man nur mit Kindern.
Ich war gestern auf der Bank, um ...
... nach Arbeitsschluss.
5'000 Fr. für das Traumauto.
Vom Munde abgespart.
3'000 kann sie
in bar auf den Tisch legen.
Der Rest folgt in kleinen Raten.
Vielen Dank.
- Danke Ihnen.
Ich musste wirklich ein Auto haben
und mir überhaupt das Gefühl geben,
dass es eine neue
und bessere Phase ist.
Und nicht nur eine neue Phase,
aber eine schlechtere.
Meissen.
Die alte neue Heimat
von Iain McKay und seiner Familie.
* Lebhafte Akustikgitarrenmusik *
Iain ist jetzt seit zwei Jahren
zurück aus der Schweiz.
Hier im Osten Deutschlands
fühlt sich der Schotte so,
wie er sich fühlen möchte.
Ähm ... zu Hause.
Ähm ... Sehr gut, ganz toll.
Gute Kontakte mit den Kollegen.
Alles läuft prima im Moment,
wirklich super.
Die Schweiz
nimmt er mit in den Unterricht.
(Englisch)
Wie sind die Schweizer als Menschen?
Was ist euer Bild
eines typischen Schweizers?
Yes? - Reich.
- Reiche Menschen. Okay. Ja?
- Schöne Landschaft.
- Beautiful landscape.
- Chocolate.
- Schokolade.
Sie kennen sich alle untereinander.
Sie leben in kleinen Dörfern.
Meine Tante lebt in so einem Dorf.
Immer, wenn wir einen Spaziergang
machen, grüsst sie alle,
die ihr entgegenkommen.
Aus seinem gescheiterten Gang in die
Schweiz macht Iain kein Geheimnis.
Das war ein interessantes Jahr.
Aber nun, ich bin wieder zurück,
es hat nicht funktioniert.
Nicht,
weil die Schweizer nicht nett wären.
Mehr deshalb, weil einige Dinge
einfach nicht wie geplant liefen.
Es ist interessant,
dass ihr von kleinen Dörfern redet.
Von Dörfern, in denen jeder jeden
kennt und wo man sich noch grüsst.
Da kann es schwierig sein,
reinzukommen.
Das ist wie
eine eingeschworene Gemeinschaft.
Wenn man von aussen dazukommt,
ist das nicht einfach.
Meissen vor fünf Jahren.
Die Welt, die Iain mit seiner Familie
damals hinter sich lassen wollte.
Meissen ist schön. Das war
ein toller Platz für elf Jahre.
Unsere Kinder
sind hier aufgewachsen.
Aber jetzt ist die Zeit reif,
weiterzugehen.
Ich mache etwas Musik an.
Denn Musik
gehört zu unserer Familie.
* Funkige Musik *
Der Umzug ins neue Leben.
Oh, Jannick, du siehst aus wie zehn.
Alle müssen noch ein letztes Mal
die Ärmel hochkrempeln
und mit anpacken.
Da sich die Familie
vorübergehend aufteilt,
geht nur ein Teil der Möbel
mit in die Schweiz.
Treibende Kraft hinter dem Umzug
war übrigens der Schotte.
Ich glaube, du musstest raus.
- Ja.
Du hast dich gefühlt
wie ein Tiger im Käfig.
Nichts ändert sich mehr
und du hattest die Hoffnung,
dass du wieder etwas bewirken
und verändern kannst.
Zunächst
scheint die Rechnung aufzugehen.
Ein Highlight der ersten Tage:
die Schülerreise in die Berge.
(Leah) I think my feet
are going to hurt. And it's cold.
Wie klein du da warst
im Vergleich zu jetzt!
Echt einen dünnen Kopf.
- Ja.
Iain entdeckt die Schönheit
der Schweizer Natur.
* Leichte, idyllische Musik *
Traumhaft.
- Schau dir diese Kulisse an!
Ich habe das
öfter in Schottland gemacht,
aber nicht auf so einer Höhe.
* Er keucht. *
Aber es tut mir gut.
Tomasee.
Oh, wow! Traumhaft.
* Vogelkrächzen *
* Klicken des Fotoapparats *
Noch einmal. Sexy time. Okay.
* Mehrmaliges Klicken
des Fotoapparats *
Okay.
* Lachen *
Thanks a lot.
- Danke, danke.
Es wäre schön, euch öfter zu sehen.
- Stimmt, das habe ich ja erzählt.
In Nordirland
trafen wir uns jeden Donnerstagabend
mit allen Lehrern
auf ein paar Drinks.
Das finde ich toll. Das hat gefehlt.
- Ja.
Ich habe euch einmal per Zufall
an einem Freitag getroffen.
Vielleicht habe ich nicht so viel
oder nicht oft genug versucht,
Kontakt aufzubauen.
Aber es war schwer.
Wir waren mehr fixiert
auf den Kontakt zwischen uns.
Es war ja für dich auch neu,
alleine mit den Mädels zu sein,
für alles verantwortlich zu sein,
zu kochen, zu waschen etc.
"Kochen".
- Thanks, Leah.
Lauch?
- Gefühlt jeden Tag Pizza.
Lauch mit Lauch?
Der Arbeitsort
des Inders Rahul Budhwar,
in der Nähe von Zürich.
Der CEO leitet eine Schweizer Firma
mit 70 Mitarbeitern.
Beruflich ist sein Gang
in die Schweiz ein Schritt nach oben.
Und inzwischen hat Rahul gelernt,
dass man auch ohne Chauffeur und
Hausangestellte ganz gut leben kann.
Besonders, wenn man
entsprechend ausgerüstet ist.
Ich habe das hier von einem
meiner Kollegen geschenkt bekommen.
Das sind offenbar
ganz wichtige Schweizer Wörter.
(Mit Akzent) "Chuchichästli".
Das ist offenbar
ein besonders schwieriges Wort.
(Mit Akzent) "Öpfelbütschgi",
"Chrut und Rüebli", "En Guete".
* Rattern *
Rahul ist kein Chef,
der sich im Büro versteckt.
Er mischt sich gerne
unter seine Schweizer Mitarbeiter.
Auch wenn er dann ständig in
Gefahr ist, Deutsch reden zu müssen.
* Stimmengewirr *
Was hast du am Wochenende gemacht?
- An diesem? - Ja.
Ähm ... wir haben ... ähm ...
Gäste zum Abendessen letzte Nacht.
Und ich habe meine Tochter
für einen Geburtstag ...
... ähm ... whatever ...
Gebringen? Gebracht?
Hast du selber gekocht
für die Einladung? - Ja, ja.
In nächster Zeit musst du zu meinem
Haus kommen fürs Abendessen.
Und ich mache ...
- Rösti? - ... Indisch.
Indische Rösti.
Nicht nur die Rösti
war eine Entdeckung.
Ich nehme mal Monika als Beispiel.
Wenn in Indien jemand
mit mir arbeitet und ich ihm sage:
"Ich brauche jetzt das und das",
dann lässt die Person
sofort alles stehen und liegen,
um es sofort zu machen, 100 %.
Aber Monika z.B. ist dann gerade
am Telefon und sagt mir:
"Stopp! Ich habe gerade zu tun."
Anschliessend macht sie's natürlich.
Und das ist auch eine gute Art.
Er kann sehr gut switchen
zwischen sehr ernst sein
und dann wieder
etwas Humor reinbringen.
Ich denke, wir Schweizer
haben das teilweise nicht so.
Wir sind so fokussiert auf unsere
Arbeit, dass wir nur ernst sind.
Dann gibt es eigentlich
keinen Witz zwischendurch,
ausser man ist unter Kollegen
und macht eine Pause.
Bei uns ist es strukturierter.
Das können wir sicher noch lernen,
dass es einen fliessenden Übergang
gibt und wir nicht so strikt sind.
(Rückblick) Das Skifahren
hast du verpasst, Rahul.
Oh, how cute.
Kannst du mich bitte hochziehen?
Das ist richtig.
Lass das, Rahul!
Du schiebst mich
in die falsche Richtung.
Geh weg! Ohne dich geht das besser.
Das kann ich inzwischen so viel
besser. Das ist wirklich peinlich.
Okay, make it parallel?
Juhuu!
Heute ziehe ich die Skier an
und fahre richtig mit Schuss.
Das Skifahren
ist eine wundervolle Sache.
Ich liebe es.
Die Berge runterfahren ist toll,
ich geniesse das jedes Mal.
Wir machen das inzwischen
zusammen mit der ganzen Familie,
das macht uns allen Spass.
Aziz ist in seinem Element.
Nach fünf Jahren in der Schweiz
ist der ehemalige Chefarzt aus Syrien
wieder halbwegs das,
was er einmal war:
Er kann als Assistenzarzt arbeiten.
Sein Arztdiplom für die Schweiz
jedoch muss er noch nachholen.
Aaah.
- Aaah.
Es ist nur rechts.
Links tut Ihnen nichts weh, oder?
Und der Mund? Können Sie den öffnen?
- Das geht.
Am Nachmittag schauen wir,
was wir machen können.
Wenn das ein Abszess ist,
werden wir operieren müssen.
Aber so weit sind wir noch nicht.
- Okay.
Mein Kollege gibt Ihnen Bescheid,
sobald wir mehr wissen. Okay?
Also, auf Wiedersehen.
- Ich komme nachher wieder vorbei.
Aziz wird vom Team geschätzt.
Möchtest du ein paar Diätkekse?
Quand tu veux, je te dis
combien de kilocalories ...
Er macht eine Menge Fortschritte
mit seinem Französisch.
Er ist ein wirklich
fröhlicher Mensch, er lacht viel.
Es ist wirklich angenehm,
mit ihm zusammenzuarbeiten.
Das stimmt,
er lacht eigentlich meistens.
Und er ist sehr diskret,
was sein Leben betrifft.
Ich hätte niemals gedacht, dass er
so schlimme Sachen erlebt hat.
Bei der Arbeit
lässt er das nie durchblicken.
Aziz' Frau
hat noch keine Arbeit gefunden.
Die Familie bekommt
kaum noch finanzielle Unterstützung.
Aziz' Lohn muss für alle reichen.
Dennoch ist er zufrieden.
Ich habe jetzt ein normales Leben.
Ich finde, das ist gut.
Ich habe mich integriert,
ich bin wieder in der Medizin tätig.
All das tut mir wirklich gut.
Noch ein halbes Jahr, dann
wird er seine Prüfung machen können.
Du hast uns wirklich gefehlt.
- Ja, ja, richtig gefehlt.
* Leichte Klarinettenmusik *
In Meissen sind Iain und Marion
zusammen mit Freunden
auf einem Integrationsfest
für Flüchtlinge.
Seit Iains Rückkehr nach Deutschland
engagieren sie sich
in diesem Bereich.
Schau mal! Hallo, grüss dich.
- Hallo.
* Stimmengewirr *
Das Fest wir von der lokalen
Flüchtlingshilfe organisiert.
Deutsche und Flüchtlinge bringen hier
gemeinsam Gärten zum Blühen.
Iain und Marion
waren fast von Anfang an mit dabei.
Hi, hallo, ich grüsse dich!
- Wie geht's?
Gut, gut. Bist du alleine hier?
- Nein. - Alle da?
Ja, mit allen Kindern, meiner Frau.
- Die habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Hi. Schön, dich zu sehen.
- Hi.
Das sind Leute aus meiner Band.
Das ist Tim. - Hallo.
Das sind Farid und das ist Greg.
- Hallo.
Genau als Iain zurückkam,
kamen die Flüchtlinge.
Das war 2015, oder? Und ...
Für uns war es fast Glück, als
plötzlich die Leute hierherkamen.
Aus Syrien,
Irak, Iran und Afghanistan.
Wir haben auch richtige Freunde.
* Lachen *
Für die Frauenquote.
Das ist richtig.
- Da ist Puppentheater.
Iain ist glücklich.
Umgeben
von seiner Familie und Freunden
lebt er
den gesellschaftlichen Austausch,
den er in der Schweiz
so sehr vermisst hat.
* Harmonische Klarinettenmusik *
* Er singt vor sich hin. *
Am Mittwoch ist Waschtag.
Am Ende gibt es wichtigere Dinge
im Leben als Haushalten.
Das stimmt.
Marion ist noch in Deutschland.
Ich habe immer
im Haushalt mitgeholfen.
Der Unterschied ist die Trennung
von mir und meiner Frau.
Wir sind nicht zusammen.
Und das tut weh.
Manchmal tut es wirklich weh.
Hi, Marion. Wir haben uns gestern
gar nicht gesehen. - Stimmt.
Hello.
- Hallo.
Wie war euer Tag?
- (Leah) Meiner war gut.
Leahs Kuchen war super.
I didn't like it.
- Nicht lecker?
Was war denn das für ein Kuchen?
- Rüebli, also Karottenkuchen.
"Rüebli."
Iains Stimmung damals:
Reinzuspringen in ein Bergdorf
ist schwer.
Geld ist nicht alles.
Und die Lebensqualität muss ...
... stimmen.
Ich finde, das geht im Moment nicht.
Der Kipppunkt war erreicht.
- Mhm.
Ich habe immer auf
einen schönen Aha-Moment gewartet.
Auf ein schönes:
"Ja, jetzt bin ich hier."
"Hurra, wir sind glücklich.
Alles läuft toll."
Aber das ist nie gekommen.
Also,  d u  wolltest wirklich
nach Dresden, nach Meissen zurück.
Ja. - Und Leah.
- Ja.
Das Jahr war halt nicht so perfekt
für mich und ich war glücklich,
dass ich wieder
in einem grossen Haus bin,
mit meinem Hund, und
dass ich meine Mutter wieder hatte.
Ich glaube,
als Teenager ist es wichtig,
eine Mutterfigur zu haben
und nicht nur einen Vater.
Ja.
Iain hat dann einen Job angenommen
in der International School,
was finanziell eigentlich
eine Katastrophe für uns war.
Das muss man mal ganz ehrlich sagen.
Das war ein Rückschritt, den wir
bis heute nicht aufgeholt haben.
Und wenn ich damals nicht
diese Lohnerhöhung bekommen hätte,
dann weiss ich auch nicht.
* Vergnügte Musik *
Lisa geht es nach vier Jahren in der
Schweiz finanziell besser als früher.
Guten Tag.
- Guten Tag.
Ich suche jetzt z.B.
einfach so ein ...
... Stockfisch-Filet für das,
was ich machen will.
Ich sehne mich
nach diesem typischen Essen.
Ich erinnere mich, als wir
mit den Eltern in Deutschland waren,
mussten wir einmal pro Woche
zum portugiesischen Laden.
Da gab es den Geschmack und das,
was man sich gewohnt ist,
was man bei uns gerne isst.
* Sie spricht portugiesisch. *
Oh, chau!
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Das hätte sogar noch mehr
kochen können. Aber es ist gut.
Früher in Portugal
hat sie selten nur für sich gekocht.
In der Schweiz isst sie auch nach
vier Jahren noch meistens alleine.
Das erinnert mich an Portugal,
wo ich
für die ganze Familie gekocht habe.
Eigentlich
würde es mir viel Freude machen,
das jemandem zu zeigen
und zum Essen zu geben.
Das würde mir noch viel mehr
Freude machen, als nur für mich.
Eigentlich hatte Lisa gehofft,
nach ihrer Scheidung
in der Schweiz
auch eine neue Liebe zu finden.
Ein Rückblick, vor vier Jahren:
Lisa ist in den Bergen unterwegs.
Und wie meistens - alleine.
* Motorengeräusche *
* Lisa seufzt. *
* Glockenbimmeln *
Ah! Meine schönen Stiefel.
Womit soll ich das jetzt putzen?
Da sieht man sofort:
Ich bin nicht vom Land.
* Kirchenglocken *
Ihre Hoffnungen,
mit einem neuen Partner
in der Schweiz ein Leben aufzubauen,
haben sich nicht verwirklicht.
Ich würde mich in vieles verlieben,
wenn ich in der Schweiz
auf Besuch bin.
Aber irgendwie ist das jetzt so ...
... dass ich nicht auf Besuch bin.
Deshalb habe ich hier
auch viele Stimmungsschwankungen.
Und ich versuche mich hier ...
... einzuleben
und das Leben geht weiter.
Meine Vorstellungen
sind immer noch da.
Und die habe ich bisher
noch nicht umsetzen können.
Weder in Portugal ...
... wo es einfacher sein sollte,
weil es meine Heimat ist.
Und hier habe ich sie
auch noch nicht umsetzen können.
* Schwere Gitarrenklänge *
* Glockenbimmeln *
Natürlich habe ich
verschiedene Männer kennengelernt.
Einige, die halt nur Kollegen sind,
oder manchmal
war auch mehr Interesse da.
Aber so richtig gefunkt
hat es bei keinem.
Also ist's halt noch ...
Oder was das ...
Ich lasse das gerne so laufen.
Wir haben noch mehr Gäste.
- Schön.
Und Wein.
- Auch schön!
Iain und Marion mangelt es
nach der Rückkehr nach Deutschland
nicht an Kontakten.
Das Haus, das sie eigentlich
für die Schweiz zurücklassen wollten,
ist zum Treffpunkt
für alte und neue Freunde geworden.
Jetzt ist das Haus
wieder voller Leben.
Fast mehr als vor dem Zeitpunkt,
als Iain weggegangen ist,
weil wir so viele
neue Freunde gefunden haben.
Von den Geflüchteten sind so viele
unsere Freunde geworden.
Im Sommer haben wir Gartenpartys,
wir grillieren und essen zusammen.
Wir sagen immer, hier bei uns
ist das United Nations Hotel.
* Jazzige Musik *
Im Musikkeller probt derweil Iain
mit seinen Musikern
für seinen Auftritt vor den Freunden.
* Englischer Gesang *
Seit seiner Rückkehr
vergeht kein Tag,
an dem er nicht unter Freunden ist.
Da, wo meine Frau ist
und wo mein Freundeskreis ist,
da ist meine Heimat.
Das habe ich gefunden.
Die Rückkehr nach Deutschland -
für seine Freunde kein Scheitern.
Das kann ich gut nachvollziehen.
Ich bin mal für ein Jahr auf
die andere Seite der USA gezogen,
das hat auch nicht funktioniert.
Du versuchst, dich anzupassen,
doch es funktioniert nicht.
Dann kommst du mit eingezogenem
Schwanz zurück und stehst vor denen,
die du zurückgelassen hast.
Fake News! - Aber das ist okay.
Es gehört zu den Lebenserfahrungen.
Mit Maske siehst du besser aus.
Verrückte Maske!
Fazit: Haben Sie Ihr Glück gefunden?
Ja ... Hier.
Uns, also mir, ist bewusst geworden,
dass wir es eigentlich
vorher schon hatten.
Das trifft es wahrscheinlich
am besten. - Ja.
Wir brauchten vielleicht
diesen Umweg, um zu realisieren,
dass wir gar keine
grosse Veränderung brauchen.
* Schlagzeug-Intro *
* Funkige Musik *
Die Familie McKay - ausgezogen,
um noch mehr Glück zu finden,
als sie bereits hatten.
Zurückgekehrt, um es dort zu finden,
wo sie es zurückgelassen hatten.
* Ruhige, funkige Musik *
Bei Lisa
geht es wesentlich ruhiger zu.
Ein arbeitsfreier Tag -
Abstand vom Alters- und Pflegeheim.
Lisa versteht es, ihrem Alltag immer
wieder positive Seiten abzugewinnen.
Wunderbar!
Da ist
richtig schön viel Fisch drin.
* Sie kichert. *
Der Geschmack
ist schon wie in Portugal,
aber das ganze Ambiente
ist natürlich etwas ganz anderes.
Da ist man schon lieber in Portugal,
aber hier tut's es auch.
Besuch von der Familie ist selten
und ein Highlight -
wie damals vor vier Jahren.
* Leichte Klarinettenklänge *
Lisa erwartet ihren Sohn Eduardo.
Er möchte das neue Leben
seiner Mutter kennenlernen.
Wann bist du angekommen, mein
Lieber? - Vor einer halben Stunde.
Wie spät war es denn?
- Halb.
Halb vier?
- Ja.
Schön hast du's hier.
- Hm?
Auf den Fotos
sah das nicht so schön aus.
Wenn du ein Kissen haben möchtest,
nimm doch das hier!
Ich bin stolz auf das,
was ich erreicht habe.
Und es freut mich, dass ich sie
bei mir habe und sie das miterleben.
Lisa möchte ihrem Sohn etwas bieten.
Sie nimmt ihn mit auf die Skipisten.
Schnee hat er noch nie gesehen.
Gar nicht so einfach!
Oh! Ich sinke ein.
Ich denke, sie hat
die richtige Entscheidung getroffen.
Ich weiss, es ist oft hart für sie.
Ich möchte sie
moralisch unterstützen
und von meiner Seite
in Portugal alles so machen,
dass sie sich
um uns keine Sorgen machen muss
und hier ihr Leben leben kann.
* Gläserne Klänge *
Irgendwie sind Lisas Söhne immer mit
dabei, auch wenn sie nicht da sind.
Jetzt werde ich
noch meinen Söhnen ...
Ich muss noch ein Foto machen.
Wo habe ich denn jetzt mein Handy?
Mein Handy ... Ich schicke das
meinen Söhnen, damit ich schön ...
Marco wird ganz glücklich sein,
weil er weiss, dass ich
portugiesisches Essen mache.
Er ist dafür,
dass ich so viel mache wie möglich,
damit ich
nicht so viel Sehnsucht habe.
Trotz Sehnsucht und Einsamkeit -
nach vier Jahren ihr Fazit:
Wenn ich zurückdenke ...
Ich hätte es wieder gemacht.
Ich wäre wieder
in die Schweiz gekommen.
Alles, was ich erlebt habe,
und alles,
was ich durchgemacht habe,
war es wert.
Weil ich bin so gewachsen.
Ich habe nicht nur zugenommen,
ich bin auch gewachsen.
Ich bin so gewachsen.
Das heisst, ich ...
Das ist eigentlich das,
was uns gross macht im Leben.
Es sind diese Lebenserfahrungen.
Ich hätte diese Lebenserfahrung
in Portugal nicht gemacht.
Das heisst,
du bist jetzt im Moment glücklich?
Ja, ich bin jetzt
nicht wunschlos glücklich.
Aber ich bin zufrieden, ja.
* Sanfte Klarinettenklänge *
In Lausanne
haben Aziz und seine Familie
v.a. eines gewonnen: Sicherheit.
Auch Aziz' Frau Sara
hat Französisch gelernt.
Auch sie möchte gerne arbeiten.
Doch bisher ist es
mit der Arbeitssuche schwierig.
Wenn Aziz arbeitet,
bin ich mit den Kindern alleine.
Da ist es schwierig,
nach einer Arbeit zu suchen
oder mich um etwas anderes
als die Kinder zu kümmern.
Zu Hause
wird v.a. kurdisch gesprochen,
auch wenn beide
die Sprache ihrer neuen Heimat
sehr schnell erlernt haben.
Noch einmal der Blick zurück auf
damals - ein Jahr nach ihrer Ankunft.
Aziz und seine Familie
haben Asyl erhalten.
Die Schweiz
bietet ihnen die erhoffte Sicherheit.
Jetzt haben sie neue Ziele.
Als Erstes: Französisch lernen.
Tag für Tag.
Ich versuche,
die Zeitformen zu erkennen.
Perfekt, Imperfekt,
Präsens, Futur und so weiter.
Im Französischen
gibt es so viele Zeitformen.
Fünf Jahre nach seiner Ankunft
zieht auch der ambitionierte Arzt
seine persönliche Bilanz.
Wir haben nur ein einziges Leben.
Wir haben eine Menge Zeit verloren.
Stellen Sie sich vor:
Wenn Sie auf einen Schlag
fünf Jahre Ihres Lebens verlieren
oder vielleicht sogar noch mehr -
einfach so.
Das ist eine Menge.
Aber für die Kinder
ist es besser hier.
In Syrien
wird die Lage immer schlimmer.
Ich hoffe, dass es sich dennoch
zum Besseren wendet.
Denn ganz ehrlich, eines Tages
möchte ich zurück nach Syrien.
Das ist mein Ziel: Eines Tages
zurückzugehen nach Syrien,
auch wenn ich nicht weiss,
wann das sein wird.
Für die Kinder ist die Schweiz
die einzige Welt, die sie kennen.
Hier wachsen sie auf
und hier gehen sie zur Schule.
Syrien kennen sie durch ihre Eltern
und aus dem Fernsehen.
Fünf Jahre nach der Flucht
vor dem Krieg
haben die Abdulkarims
ein Leben in der Schweiz.
Was sie als Heimat definieren,
werden Eltern und Kinder
sicher in Zukunft diskutieren müssen.
* Fliessende Klarinettenklänge *
Das dritte Jahr in der Schweiz.
An die Hausarbeit haben sich
Megha und Rahul inzwischen gewöhnt.
So ist das Leben.
Während die einen hart arbeiten,
geniessen die anderen ihr Leben.
Ich habe Dia fertigt gemacht, zur
Schule gebracht und wieder abgeholt.
Das sind sicher 2, 3 Std. Arbeit.
Ich denke,
wenn wir die Stunden zählen,
habe ich locker mehr gemacht als du.
Wirklich?
- Ja.
Darüber werden wir
wohl noch öfter diskutieren.
Cheers!
- Cheers!
Mit 30 lernen wir jetzt endlich,
wie es ist,
für uns selbst zu sorgen.
Niemand,
der einem das Essen serviert,
und die Kleidung wäscht sich
auch nicht mehr von alleine
und ist auf magische Weise
immer zum Tragen bereit.
Für Schweizer Verhältnisse
kommt das sicher ein wenig spät.
Aber immerhin - wir machen das.
Schweizer im Alltag,
Inder im Herzen.
Ganz ehrlich,
manchmal vermisse ich die Familie,
wenn ich einfach
zu viel um die Ohren habe.
Dann vermisse ich,
was wir in Indien hatten.
Manchmal vermisse ich
die Wärme der Grossfamilie.
Oder wenn wir mal ausgehen wollen
und einen Babysitter brauchen -
das sind so die Momente, in denen
wir unser altes Zuhause vermissen.
Auch an die beiden Inder die Frage:
War es das wert?
Ich denke, das ist es absolut wert.
Abgesehen vom Beruflichen ist es
v.a., sich mit anderen Menschen,
Kulturen und Lebensarten
auseinanderzusetzen.
Wenn man reist
und neue Menschen trifft,
wird man ein offenerer Mensch.
Man wird offener
und als Mensch reifer.
Ich würde das sofort wieder machen.
Keine Frage.
Als ich in Indien war,
hatte ich eine eher traditionelle
Sicht auf das Leben.
Heiraten, Karriere, Kinder kriegen,
ein normales Leben führen.
Ich war viel weniger offen
für Neues.
Jetzt, nachdem ich
hier in die Schweiz gekommen bin,
bin ich eher bereit,
auch mal ein Risiko einzugehen.
Ich bin offener geworden.
Hier merke ich,
dass wir nur ein Leben haben
und es wirklich leben müssen.
Ich denke, in dieser Hinsicht
habe ich mich verändert -
ich traue mich eher,
Dinge auszuprobieren,
glücklich zu leben, anstatt
nur auf die Karriere zu achten.
Heute gibt es mehr andere Dinge,
die mein Leben inspirieren.
Die beste Kleidung, das beste Auto,
das beste Restaurant -
das alles hat für uns
nicht mehr so viel Bedeutung.
Aber Zeit zusammen zu verbringen,
das ist wirklich wichtig.
Stimmt, also
kauf nicht ständig neue Klamotten!
* Beschwingte Streicherklänge *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Maria Krähenbühl - 2019
* Tragende Streicherklänge *